Well that sounds great, but
how will be go about building
this interactive prototype?
We'll need a tool to build it.
What we're looking for
has three key aspects.
First there's interactivity.
We only want tools that allow us
to build a clickable prototype.
All the better if that prototype can be
interacted with on the target device.
This is the fundamental part of
medium fidelity prototyping so
it's non-negotiable.
We also want something that is fast.
We are busy entrepreneurs, and we don't
have time to waste on learning a complex
tool for this task or on building
a prototype in a time consuming way.
This is fundamental to all prototyping,
remember.
We always want the fastest version
that will meet our requirements and
get us the info we need.
Finally, we'll want to be able to
get that info from the right people.
Sometimes, the right people for
the job are far away,
which means that we'll want a tool
that makes it just as easy to get
feedback from someone halfway across the
globe as someone halfway down the block.